so why did we make a daisy video what is
that game isn't it like a mod yeah well
it's a mod but it's also just a really
amazing zombie variant Sambi world and
universe most zombie like TV shows and
movies they focus a lot on simply these
zombies trying to come and get you
comin after you but like in dayz there's
a very interesting turn which we decided
to focus on for the video which is the
fact that in the zombie apocalypse slow
zombies aren't a big deal we just shoot
them on the run that yeah they're stupid
but you really have to worry about is
the other people and survivors out there
who possibly are more well equipped for
the apocalypse than you are played a lot
of dayz
throughout the summer when the mod came
out and stop at around the fall so we
wouldn't burn ourselves up before the
standalone came out yep
I'll they enough a lot of stuff he
released everybody says hey this looks a
lot like Daisy it's like our inherent
style naturally lines up with that a
daisy and Minnesota especially in the
fall looks a lot like the countryside in
fact we have a wide shot of the city
where you see a factory and a power
plant and a grain elevator all in the
same shot Mattie
oh no there's no effects there it's like
that's just it's downtown st. Paul next
to the river I'm from Stillwater Sam's
from Stillwater
Brandon's from Stillwater and Henry the
guy runs a minute physics not quite from
Stillwater he's like 15 minutes away he
was actually out for the first day of
the shoot up and out it's really strange
this like small talent is managed like
breed various large YouTube channels
factoid complete factoid complete that's
what we good watching now why is it in
the snow you asked because obviously the
game isn't sent like in that kind of
landscape we figured this that this
takes place after the events of like the
mod or the game so it's a little bit
longer into the post-apocalyptic setting
people have kind of figured their stuff
out snow has fallen and it kind of puts
a twist in the environment because
people have to really be prepared to
live in this kind of environment
yeah it's fan fiction and so we also
went with the idea of two people that
don't speak the same language a guy he
was rushing the guy who was American
we've intentionally not given you
subtitles the Russian
yeah so that way if you don't know rush
and you're in the same position that the
American is and vice versa if you're
Russian it's not the zombies that are
the threats the other people it's all
about the personal conflicts and what
kind of scenarios are gonna deal with in
this like very unique setting
so from production like this we were
home over Christmas break we took some
time off as you guys probably tell our
channels have been kind of quiet for the
past month and that's because every once
in a while I just got take it easy yeah
we go on vacation to refresh your
batteries yes we do go so we planned out
this piece while you're home just took
the time kind of talked about cool ideas
walked around at the various locations
plan things out and eventually kind of
got a basic storyline and then after
doing some more location scouting kind
of working out the actions it was
finally time to shoot videos about nine
minutes long to shoot a nine minute
piece like this took us about three days
you know realistically two or three
minutes a day some action some dialogue
and you can't really fit anything else
in especially considering we're shooting
with the Sun and in Minnesota in the
winter that means you have like 20
minutes of daylight doing a three-day
shoot also give us a little more time to
just kind of relax and get a bunch of
set ups and get some cool shots and not
really have to stress out about anything
terms of the actors we work with Sasha
who wasn't teather as you guys might
recall I'm sure we're going to confuse a
couple people with the overlap there is
this tether tether and his friend Paul
was the the other guy the main guy
also thanks to Ryan and Matt for coming
out the two guys that run the airsoft
channel yeah we used to guys were
totally loaded up with sweet tactical
gear and so he tweeted that out too and
they responded and I they had the most
tactical yourself here I think I've ever
seen actually because they've shotguns
sling shot gun a pistol a PDW and then
this guy is like a Masada AKM thing
that's just I've never even heard of
that guy so everyone knows that action
essentials are getting old you know
everyone recognizes the same blood hits
blood verso one specifically all over
the place they're even used in the
Walking Dead - check this out though so
for this one we decided all right let's
make some custom hits for blood that we
can use that look really cool and really
sweet in order to do this I happen for
my favorite liquid stimulation program
realflow famously used in a potion
overdose so
and started making some little bullet
hits for blood so check these eight so
basically for this piece of
experimenting with doing like
high-velocity real flow simulations I
have no idea if it's working it because
to make liquids that are really fast
traveling look right you need to make
sure like the scale of everything's
correct the frame rate you're working at
is correct but also how fast is the bolt
traveling how fast would that really be
making this liquid flow so I'm just
gonna sit here for a few hours trying to
figure this out
day two of making a CG blood basically
starting to find that the way real blood
acts has no bearing on what I'm doing
here because never before in a movie
have people used real blood
as for squibs so basically I'm just
trying to work with the surface tension
and the like the viscosity essentially
which is how how much clumps together
and versus how runny it is to make a
good hit following up the gravity right
seen scale and so from here on out just
gonna render it out and see if it looks
good we can't with the idea or
strategize that we went through the
full-blown zombie horde until night time
because we wanted to light that scene
with a flare and it is actually just lit
with a flare
I had a big light on a pole so like I
could beat people around this is a young
kid with the power of his magic like
light staff and Gandalf didn't like bust
out any good spells in the entire
lowering strange I know he busts out the
lens flare spell and now look everyone
on youtubes just that's the only spell
they know oh we talked about tether
briefly you mentioned that cuz
everything good
sokka's something we shot a piece of
Minnesota and there's a bunch of stone
we have the same actress Heather I'm
sure a bunch people were like why didn't
you just shoot each other everybody do
do another part of each other it's going
to be part of a big project it's either
going to be a film or web series of some
sort of long-form story a lot like how
we did sync we are working out believe
it or not it is not dead but we're not
gonna say anything until we can give you
guys some solid information and you know
what's up so don't worry still in the
works also this project would not have
been possible without the help from our
fans and everybody else who's out in
Minnesota
quite literally everyone says that
everyone says we couldn't done it
without the fans but literally we
literally couldn't have shot this
without the fan any good zombie video
you need a lot of zombies you need a
horde and so we did is we actually tweet
it out and facebooked out to all our
followers in Minnesota in the
Minneapolis st. Paul area come on out
and be zombies for an evening with us
it's really awesome
hopefully we get a chance to take
advantage of fanbase and everybody out
there who follows us and do something
like this again whether it's in Los
Angeles we're going to saw it or any
other place we end up so you guys
everything this is something that'd be
cool to partake in we should follow us
on Twitter or Facebook I promise you
won't be disappointed by our quality
tweets
they're so good but more than anything
else is just really awesome having a
chance to kind of like meet people in
person and talk with them and also
simply you know shoot something really
cool and make something
so yeah turned out well I think all our
friends and all our fans that everybody
else who helped on this production it
really meant a lot so thank you very
much for helping us
[Music]